[Musique]
oui sous trois ris fait pas le riz en
français je préfère parler en français
parce que je suis actuellement ce précis
je suis membre de l'observatoire hugo de
l'université de liège
je suis venu au bénin le week-end
dernier dans le cas de cette
présentation est dans le cadre de la
remise de parchemins à des journalistes
que nous avons formés au nom de
l'observatoire hulot nous parlerons ce
soir de nourrir le bénin face aux
catastrophes climatiques en tant qu
auteur du livre péjoration climatique au
bénin j'ai découvert que les trente
dernières années font l'objet d'une
réelle contraction pluviométrique au
binaire et qui est lui d'énormes
préjudices ou les rendements agricoles
les paysans désormais confrontés à cette
catastrophe climatique qui d'ailleurs
l'année dernière a fait l'objet d'une
évasion céréalières des chenilles dans
les champs de maïs a induit d'énormes
préjudices pour les rendements agricoles
cette situation entraîne le déplacement
des populations büro für alle des
villages vers les villes et entraîne la
bête de la biodiversité entre elles ce
qu'on appelle la fragmentation du
couvert végétal est en train de la
différence utilisation des sols la
baisse des pluies en face d'un pays où
l'agriculture est quasiment pluviales
induit d'énormes conséquences dans une
ère que nous appelons désormais une aire
de la nosfell du vêtement
ce qu'ils veulent à skis un russe qui a
pu démontrer que l'homme de par son
intelligence de par l'intelligence
technologique a pu dénaturaliser les
milieux naturels et 7 des
naturalisations d'un milieu naturel qui
aclr le réchauffement climatique la
déglaciation des calottes polaires la
transgression marine l'élévation du
niveau de la mer aujourd'hui aclr la
salinisation des eaux dodoz côtière au
bénin et les phénomènes de trophies à
sion nos paysans qui désormais
confrontés à des terres de plus en plus
convoité par des étrangers dans j'ignore
le nom à ce moment aux objets de
d'agression pas de stress
pas de stress pose aujourd'hui la
question du foncier rural
nous sommes dans un pays où nous avons
la basse vallée du fleuve vous aimez une
vallée qui est la plus riche la deuxième
la plus riche au monde après le nil mais
nous constatons les trente dernières
années que cette vallée subi le
phénomène d'eutrophisation qui en
réalité la pollution liés aux pesticides
duo coton et ses pesticides engendre de
nos jours ce qu'on appelle le
bouleversement de la niche écologique de
plus des espèces et cette niche
écologique se définit par un écosystème
favorable un environnement favorable au
développement d'une espèce donnée
bouleversant ainsi la vie et le mode de
vie le cycle de vie des chenilles
entraîne la taille de ces chenilles dans
les champs de maïs
les paysans qui au départ confronté par
la baisse plus vieux métriques désormais
confrontés par l'anp propos scène qui
est laid géologique quasiment associée à
l'homme de par son intelligence sont
désormais bouleversé à la quête du gain
facile
obligés de se déplacer des villages vers
les villes nous rencontrons de plus en
plus d éminemment nous rencontrons de
plus en plus des games nous
rencontrerons
de plus en plus des pauvres qui seront
obligés de vivre dans le lit
d'écoulement des cours d'eau à scélérat
ainsi les risques d'inondations la
vulnérabilité à l'inondation dans les
zones côtières du bénin aujourd'hui
notre pays est plus que jamais
confrontés au défi de la promotion de
l'agriculture familiale
nous sommes désormais confrontés au défi
de la promotion d'un circuit court et
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pas un circuit
court c'est tout simplement la promotion
des des produits agricoles provenant de
nos petits cultivateurs que
l'importation des produits venant de
l'étranger
nous sommes de plus en plus confrontés à
la consommation et à l'intoxication
chronique dans notre alimentation de
produits venant de l'étranger
dans l'est le glyphosate le glyphosate
qui fait l'objet aujourd'hui d'une
réelle problématique au sein de la
commission européenne et il y a deux
semaines j'étais avec josé bové
en belgique on a eu à prélever lui le
grand défenseur de l'environnement
on a eu à relever ses cheveux ses urines
on a constaté qu'ils assurent pesticides
dans ses urines et dans ses cheveux non
qui sommes ici au bénin en décembre
dernier notre pays a eu encore à faire
sauter d'un décret qui font la promotion
de ce griffon that pour le coton nous
sommes interpellés
notre conscience est interpellé
allons-nous avoir une économie qui vont
faire entrer de l'argent mais qui met en
jeu la santé des populations
nous sommes interpellés allons nous
continuer à avoir des boulangeries qui
utilise du brommat de potassium pour
conseiller du pain à la place du blé
nous sommes interpellés
allons nous continuer à consommer du
poisson grillé qui impôts liés aux
dioxines nous sommes interpellés
allons nous continuer à consommer des
produits congelés provenant de
l'extérieur qui sont des ogm et qui nous
exposent à la leucémie
nous sommes interpellés nous sommes
désormais interpellé par notre
conscience et nous n'avons plus le choix
que de faire la promotion du local est
aujourd'hui l'une des dernières
recommandations que j'en fais c'est tout
simplement que le bénin
même si le bénin ne pouvait sortir du
franc cfa aujourd'hui est obligé d'avoir
de la monnaie locale
j'ai participé le mois de janvier le
mois de février au parlement jeunesse
développement durable de la wallonie
malgré que la belgique utilisent l'euro
comme monnaie
aujourd'hui les dernières
recommandations que nous avons formulées
à la wallonie c'est des recommandations
en termes de monnaie locale
c'est des recommandations en termes
d'économie circulaire où nous avoir
l'obligation de recycler les déchets
provenant de l'agriculture pour répondre
aux besoins de la démographie galopante
et aux besoins de l'économie durable
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]